eight news now prepping you for the big
game we got recipes I promise they're
going to be a hit at your watch party so
I went over to Nellie's Southern Kitchen
inside MGM Grand Chef Mario showed us
five game Day recipes it is now Thursday
so we're day four meatball sliders get
ready
you gotta have some meat and some carbs
and some flavor so what do we got we're
gonna do just some traditional meatball
sliders here it sounds so easy he makes
it sound so easy it's only a few
ingredients very simple you can use your
already made marinara of your choice
okay here I just have some ground beef
and sausage a little Italian parsley and
uh parmesan cheese we got just a little
bit of butter in there
and then we just want to wait make sure
and it's hot what's the key to not
overcooking the meatball you don't want
it to be tough right and what you want
to do is you want to make sure the
outside is a nice golden brown it
doesn't have to be done and then finish
in the oven ah okay finish in the oven
don't overcook here because it's going
to cook a little more later they're
gonna and it's gonna cook in your sauce
and that's why a lot of people don't
understand when they're doing it is that
no matter it's going to continue cooking
what's a typical time frame couple
minutes
10 to 12 minutes I just want to make
sure that every inch of that meatball is
coated and there's all somewhat equal
color once you get that golden brown
consistency that you want you're just
going to then pour your marinara on top
make sure we got plenty of sauce on
there
the more sauce the better the more sauce
the better so then I'm just going to
layer those oh yeah that's the provolone
provolone cheese perfect it's just a
little bit of that sweet basil on there
all right and then we're just going to
top these and we're gonna cook them
straight in the oven
and I'm gonna let those go for about
five minutes and when they come out I'm
gonna brush the top of them with
Parmesan cheese and melted butter is
there ever too much butter never too
much butter
never too much
that's the southern glue I think so what
I would do
is have a bigger plate and you can put
the marinara in the middle so you can
dip and enjoy Super Bowl Perfection
thanks Chef thank you thanks for having
us all right so did you catch that never
enough butter and then he also did tell
me never enough cheese so there you go
full recipe instructions on our website
eightnewsnow.com